this program is being presented to you
by the heras international winter school
on gravity and
[Music]
light good morning welcome back to the
third lecture today's lecture is lecture
three
multilinear
algebra
and of course all of you will have had a
course on Vector spaces on linear
algebra and multi-linear algebra is the
same field it just emphasizes that you
might not only look at linear Maps but
multi-linear maps and the essential
element of or the object of study of
multilinear algebra is just Vector
spaces however uh a word of warning uh
from the beginning we will
not we will
not
equip
space or later space time physical space
or space time with a vector space
structure you might think we would
because before we had a set and we
equipped it with a topological structure
with a topology and in fact
that is one step towards the picture of
space time now today we'll talk about
and this lecture we'll talk about
equipping a set with a vector space
structure and but if this doesn't
further our aim of describing SpaceTime
why do we do it and it doesn't further
this aim and um I emphasize this only
because often it is assumed that space
physical space or physical space time
carries a vector space structure um and
I do not want to enter into into the
discussion now but my question would be
if physical SpaceTime the positions
carried a vector space structure then
you should know or here as a question or
do you
know where five times Paris
lies where is five times Paris does that
make any sense or where does
Paris plus
Vienna
lie
there is no such notion on physical
position space to add places to add
positions or to multiply them by real
numbers so we will not equip space time
with a vector space structure so however
why do we look into this the tangent
spaces and that's a notion that is
deceptively intuitive but in fact bear
with me until we Define it precis ly but
the tangent spaces they have a name
TPM to a type of manifold we're going to
discuss in the fourth lecture today to
smooth
manifolds so TPM will be constructed in
lecture five to uh on Friday uh and
these are objects that can be uh written
down for smooth manifolds and smooth
manifolds will be defined in lecture
four
today the tension space to smooth
manifolds very roughly you can think of
them but in fact we will Define them
differently if this is the real world
say a sphere then you could for instance
think of the tension space attached to
the North Pole P this is a TPM but you
could at any other point of your real
world you could attach another Point Q
you have another tangent Point here and
on the sphere you have many different
tangent spaces in fact we won't Define
them in this way it will be slight
defined slightly differently but the
point is whatever way you define them
these guys they carry a vector space
structure and the natural one at that so
even though the underlying position
space space space time does not carry a
natural T um Vector space structure the
tangent spaces do
and the tangent spaces once you have
them you have a vector space here you
have a derived notion there that's the
notion of a tensor and tensors are very
important in differential geometry and
it's best to First understand them
abstractly so um the
advantage well it's
beneficial to First
study Vector
spaces and all that comes with it
abstractly so we could enter immediately
into studying these concrete Vector
spaces but the point is this is for two
reasons it's better to have this lecture
three as we have it today the first
reason is even in the exact
construction of the TPM for
construction of TPM
which will be a finite dimensional
Vector space all this will be defined
one
needs an
intermediate Vector
space which is again a vector space
which is called C Infinity m whatever
that will
be um and so you cannot even construct
this guy without understanding
previously what Vector spaces are
abstractly so it is worthwhile doing
that and the second is that uh
tensors or tensor techniques so the
definition and what you do with them
tensor techniques are um most
easily
understood in an abstract setting where
you don't have to worry about this
specific Vector space and its details
but tensors are something that are
defined on any Vector space are most
easily understood in an abstract
context or in an abstract
setting this is the reason why for a
moment we leave our aim where it is but
consider multilinear
algebra so first section is Vector
spaces as I said Vector spaces are the
object that is being studied in linear
algebra and you certainly saw the
definition nevertheless let me repeat it
the definition is a vector
space is a triple consisting of a set
and two operations plus and times so uh
where a vector space is first of all a
set V and I don't call it M because it's
not the M we had before we're going to
equip with a vector space structure
later on so if you later on want to
identify uh this V we're now talking
about will for most of the rest of the
course be a TPM at a certain point or an
another at another Point okay that's
where we're going to apply
it um second you have a so-called
addition but what is an addition an
addition is a map why because it takes
two vectors
and it Maps them to a vector if you have
such a rule you have an addition and the
third element is you have an S
multiplication it's not a multiplication
it's an S multiplication what does that
mean that's okay I should say a real
Vector space an R Vector space and this
s multiplication takes a real number in
the vector and it converts it into a
vector so it's not a multiplication
between two vectors that has nothing to
do with the vector space structure okay
and in order to distinguish this we call
this an S
multiplication where of course the S May
stand for scalar multiplication but I
will never use that word so it's an S
multiplication and um of course not any
such triple is a vector
space it has to satisfy how many
axioms eight it's K me
and
Adu key and Adu key is the commutative
law the associative law the neutral
existence of a neutral element and the
existence of inverse elements with
respect to the
addition let's look at those first and
remind ourselves of those you have a
vector v and you have a vector W then
you can always you always have the
Symmetry it's commutative that's a
requirement on this plus the associative
law U Plus V in Brackets plus W well you
can shift the brackets U plus v + W
brackets shifted now this is of course
true for all V and W in the vector space
that is what I mean I could write this
out but you you know this already okay
for all V and W it's true for all UV W
it's true now the existence of a neutral
element we got to be careful there
exists a vector call it circle circle in
v
it one of those exists such that for all
V in V it is true that V plus circle is
again
V of course Circle we read it as zero
but it's not the zero in the real
numbers it's the zero in the vector
space call it Circle if you wish inverse
elements that's a little bit the other
way around this is one in one for all
that's the the musketeer principle but
this is for all the exists One V in V
there exists a vector which we just
denote by the symbol minus V in V it's
just a symbol it's just ensure it lies
in there such that v+ minus V is this
neutral element hence this law has to
come first so can you can use this
neutral element here and of course um
one may write V minus V equal Z as a
short notation for V plus minus V but
the point is there is such a vector
minus V
then you have an associative law you
have two distributive laws and um these
guys here they only refer to the plus
and all of these four laws they connect
these
two okay or connect them to the uh plus
and times on R uh well the associative
law very quickly it's uh Lambda time mu
* V equal Lambda * mu * V and now let's
be very careful
because the plus here and the S
multiplication here maybe it's
worthwhile marking them in red for a
while because this is the Plus on the
vector space this is all the Plus on the
vector space okay um this is the plus
here this is the plus there and this is
all on the vector space but here this is
the times on the vector space because
these Lambda and
mu are supposed to be from the real
numbers and you see here this is the
times on the vector space because a real
number times a vector that's this guy
the result is a vector so I again have
to multiply it by a real
number but this times here this is the
multiplication on the real numbers and
that's a different thing so we use the
dot in both cases but it's useful to use
colors at the moment okay then there two
distributive laws Lambda plus mu time
V equals Lambda V + mu V okay this is of
course on the vector space this is
between real numbers this is on the
vector space on the vector space and
this is on the vector
space and there's another distributive
law namely Lambda * V + mu time no plus
Lambda time W again Vector space Vector
space Vector space
equals Lambda * V +
W Vector space Vector space okay and the
unitary law looks a little trivial but
it's important 1 * V is again V and
that's of course this and this is the
one from the real numbers okay so any
structure of this type that satisfies
these aums is Vector
space now a word of
terminology a
vector is an
element or I I I formulate differently
an
element of a Vector
space is
often referred
to and I emphasize
informally as a
vector so you must not ask the question
what is a vector well you can and then
I'll say it's an element of a vector
space but the question is if I put you
one vector here I put one here however I
do this and I ask you is it a vector or
not the point is you don't know uh I
make this
uh this remark in a second again and
you'll you'll understand what I mean now
of course you all have in your mind R to
the three as an example a prime example
of a vector space and R3 can be made
into a vector space it's not a vector
space all by
itself and last night when we decided
what examples to present into today's
lecture we looked in makaveli's book The
Prince again and there he says you have
to do the cruel things in the
beginning now the cruel thing I'm going
to do I will not give you a single
directly intuitive example that makes
contact to what you know about Vector
spaces why don't I do that because you
will probably imagine more than what I
write down I don't want that I will give
you an example for just everything we
construct today which are perfect
example
but which are not quite immediately
unless you're a mathematician make you
think oh that's what I always thought
what vectors are but that will force you
to sharpen your understanding of the
definitions okay that's it and in the
tutorials uh you then will be reconciled
with the abstract notion and RN appears
at some
point so the one example I will employ
again and again for all constructions is
the following I first Define the set
Define the
set P it's just what I call it it's the
set of all maps small P so it's a big p
of small Maps small P from the real
interval minus one to + one into the
real numbers but not just any of those I
just look at those that as a map can be
written as some n equal 0 to some
capital N uh with some coefficients call
them PN so they are from the real
numbers times x to the N or in other
words this is the set of
pols of let's say fixed n capital N
equal 7 fixed uh
degree polom is defined on this part of
the real life
x² for instance or 2 + x to 7 if n is
great capital N is greater than 7 okay
it's a collection of such objects it's a
collection of functions of polinomial
okay it's a set and at this stage I can
ask a very simple question or somebody
might ask a simple question or might
think might think
is p oh no is
square a
vector now you ask what on Earth is
square well where square is a map that
takes an X and produces x
squared right it's the x squared polom
but as a map as an element in here it
has a name it's called
Square and square is the function that
sends X to X squar okay is square a
vector you might be thinking that and
uh you should get the resounding answer
no square is an element of the set P but
there is no addition and there is no s
multiplication defined anywhere around
so how can you even talk about a vector
if you didn't talk about a vector space
in the first place excuse me I was
already wondering that when you us what
is five times Paris yes if I take Paris
if I Define multiplication by say we
take the and we take five times each
coordinate and things like that then I
can tell you what five times I said five
times Paris but that's just um if you
really believe in this I tell you at
seven times Paris I I hid a
treasure1 million EUR really it's really
true go and find it where do you go tell
me where tell me now where do you go
that's exactly point you said if I have
a vector space I have to Define what I
understand yes addition multiplication
it it will become clear it will become
clear later okay was just my M it was
just my motivation to say we will not
equip physical SpaceTime with this
structure we can discuss this for half
an hour and I'm sure I'm sure in the end
you will
agree but but let me now let me let me
let me proceed here it's true you could
say I Define it my point is that
physical SpaceTime doesn't carry the
structure you could say in my picture
mathematical picture I Define it but you
will find nothing in the world that
justifies it that's my point but let's
not enter this discussion I I I beg you
okay we'll come back to this okay so
there is no it's not a vector at this
stage now what we can of course do I can
add I can define an
addition which I do the following way I
can do this any time any way I want if I
can show the aoms afterwards I take one
polinomial and another one that what it
means to have an element in here and I
MA this to what I then call p+ Q it's of
course the colored plus okay maybe here
at this point I still use it so this is
the the color plus the color plus and
how is this defined well this is the sum
of two polinomial what I do I mean by
this
I mean the sum of two pols is a polom
defined by if I act on X it's p of X
Plus Q of X so you say well you wrote
nothing new you said the sum is the sum
well this is the sum on P but this here
is the addition on the real numbers
because P of X is an element in R this
plus I have and if you wish I Define
this plus by this plus over here by this
construction this sum of polinomial is
the
polinomial that is the sum whose whose
um value is the sum of the values okay
that's the trick that's the trick
here and uh similarly I can define an S
multiplication R cross P into P now I
take a real number Lambda in the
polinomial p i ma this to Lambda time p
and this is the times here the s
multiplic ation and again I need to say
what kind of polom or what polom this is
this is a polom whose value is given by
Lambda times the value of the polinomial
and this is again the r in the real
numbers okay good
now the question can come up again
exactly the same
question is box a vector somebody asks
box is still box box is still this
polinomial now I have this structure
defined and now somebody might
say yes but who
cares the point is you can't look at
this guy and say it is a vector because
this guy is just an element of a set
that May underly a vector space but in a
sense you ask is this a vector and it
depends on whether in the background you
define this or not however if somebody
insists this is a vector but cannot tell
you how to add it to another Vector to
another element of the space then he or
she is in trouble so in a sense you can
say are these two things vectors well if
you can't add them you're in bad shape
okay but you see it's a bad question
actually because being an element of
something only refers to the underlying
so I should first write p+
times p+ times is a vector space and of
course one has to check these aums and
uh I'm sure you can and I'm sure this is
easy P plus times is a vector space but
if you say a vector is an element of a
vector space that's fine like this guy
but it only refers to the underlying set
so somehow it's not a good question is
something a vector but you can certainly
talk about Vector spaces that's all I
want to say because in in relativity
there's often the question what is a
tensor what is it and a vector is a
special type of tensor how do I see
something is a tensor you don't you can
only Define tensor spaces and you may
informally call its elements tensors
vectors are an example that's my point
okay I rather want to discourage you by
this word formally from using the
terminology at all of course I myself
will not adhere to this
advice okay so this was uh the first
section question so far one brief
question how would you this when
recommend us to rephrase the sentence a
quantum mechanical State we usually
describe as a vector in a hbert space
well a state would be array in the
Hilbert space instead of a vector but a
from that ah sorry question so the
question was how I would rephrase the
statement in quantum mechanics a quantum
mechanical state is an element is a
vector in the Hilbert space I would say
it's an element of a Hilbert space uh
although a state a quantum mechanical
state is a ray in Hilbert space not a
vector itself because there's ambiguity
with the phase and the and the norm okay
but uh it would say it's an element of
the Hilbert space why would I have to
say to call it a vector okay good
um
so now linear
Maps it's a standard procedure in
mathematics once you have an object
defined a structure a space with certain
structure that you investigate the
structure by considering Maps between
one such structure and another instance
of such a structure we did this in
topology we took one topological space
and another topological space and we
studied Maps between them which
preserved or respected the structure in
topology it was the open set structure
pre-images of open sets are open here if
we want to follow this General
philosophy of studying structures by
studying structure uh respecting Maps we
need to look at so-called linear Maps so
these
are the
structure
uh
respecting Maps between Vector
spaces you ask why would I look at
structure respecting Maps the answer is
this is always a good idea to learn more
at any structural level so we do this
here and they're just called for out of
tradition they're called linear Maps so
if V plus s multiplication is a vector
space and I write plus v and plus
and and S multiplication V the addition
and S multiplication on V and W plus on
W and S multiplication on W they need to
have nothing to do with each other right
let these be Vector
spaces any two Vector spaces you
like then a map F from V to W you see
the map again only refers to the
underlying set sets because if you know
how one element goes to the other you
have that then the map is
called
linear if two conditions are satisfied
the first one is f of V plus v twiddle
is f of V plus F of V twiddle and for
all V and V twiddle and the second is f
of Lambda * V equals uh Lambda Time 5 of
V for all V in the vector space and
Lambda real numbers but now the question
is which plus is which and which s
multiplication is which you tell me this
is the Plus
on V this is the Plus
on
W this is the S multiplication
on V and this is the S multiplication on
pardon me
W so you see really both goes in now all
these four operations go into the
definition of a linear map it connects
these spaces somehow very special Maps
only will have this
property again as much as you in top you
can only talk about continuity of a map
if the set carries more structure namely
a topology is the same here this is a
map but you can only call it linear if
you know about a vector space structure
on both of these sets before that you
cannot ask is the map linear again I
just write down any map for you and ask
you is it linear you say I don't know
unless you tell me what the additional s
multiplication on the domain and the
target are okay it's very
important so also for maps you cannot
say it's linear or not unless you define
addition and
multiplication so it means also on R to
the three you have to say how to add two
triples of real numbers and usually you
say you add them component wise but
that's let's say entrywise and how do
you multiply them by a Scala you say
well you pull the scalar into each
entry if you say this then you made the
set
R3 into a vector space and all of a
sudden you know what the sum of two
elements in R3 is but before you specify
this the definition of plus and
definition of times you simply can't
even think about it okay that's the
point and again it's like with the
standard topology you have been
indoctrinated to always do this addition
in a certain way and therefore it seems
a natural
choice but it's not so natural natural
in mathematics canonical always means
with the structure already given you can
uniquely construct it
okay but if you have to say more if it's
not obvious if if you have to say more
like take it component wise or pull the
Lambda into each entry that's additional
information this additional information
is
structure okay so there is nothing
natural about adding two elements in R3
by adding its individual entries
entrywise nothing natural about it you
may call it natural because used to it
but that's not a good definition of
natural because it depends on your
history and again that's not a good
theorem in
mathematics
okay so
um let me give you an example for a
linear
map and of course I provided you with
only one example of a vector space so
I'm forced to do the example uh as a
linear map from P to P okay okay that's
the space of these pols of degree at
most some fixed capital n and I call
this map Delta from P2 p i prescribe it
as follows I take a
polom and delt and it's sent to the
polinomial Delta of P which is defined
as now I need to give you a specific one
well I take the derivative of
p p is a polinomial in one variable I
can take its derivative the result will
be a polom right derivative of polom is
so I take a polom and you'll get a polom
so the linear map I just described is
the differentiation
operator because the map is just the
operator of
deriving okay so why is it linear let's
check what do I have to check I have to
check whether the Delta of a PO
polinomial plus another polom well let's
see what it is uh this is uh p + Q the
Pol the sum this is of course the Plus
on P is the Plus on P
derived but you know the sum rule of
differentiation which of course not only
applies to pols but in particular to
pols this is the derivative of one polom
plus the derivative of another
polinomial and it's again the Plus in P
but this is
Delta of p plus Delta of Q ah the
sum the the image of the sum is the sum
of the images ahuh good first second
Delta of Lambda p is lamb P derivative
is Lambda * P derivative is Lambda *
Delta of p Ah second axm also satisfied
indeed Delta is a linear
map so the differ operator acting on
pols in this case for Simplicity is a
linear
map fine um notation in order to not
always have to say this is a linear map
if F from V to W V and W equipped with
plus and S multiplication
linear we usually write for this by
definition f v w and I put a little
twiddle on here this means it's a linear
map from V to W that saves a lot of
writing
okay a very
important question is as always if you
have a vector space V in a vector space
w and the vector space capital
u and you have linear Maps uh F and S
going from V to W and another linear map
from w to you that's called f sometimes
I put the twiddle underneath okay the
question is what about the map f after s
what about it and the claim is uh if
these two are linear then this one is
linear and the diagram says it all you
can go this way or that way if these two
are linear You can conclude this one is
linear the composition of linear Maps is
linear in fact this comp position is
what if you are
so well so arbitrary as to introduce a
basis on your vector space and I will
only introduce a basis at the very end
of today's lecture because in order to
really understand what's going on you
must not introduce a basis it uh clouds
your thinking forget the basis you need
to understand everything like this but
um later on this will be essentially
explain the matrix multiplication rule
rule if you make additional provisions
of how you store the information in such
a linear map okay so lots of the rules
you know are very Arcane rules with lots
of rules and information for very simple
facts this is the very simple fact this
explains everything about matrix
multiplication okay but don't worry
about it so this is
um okay good okay so that's the
composition of linear Maps is linear uh
example for the usefulness of this well
in our example you can look at Delta
after Delta Delta after Delta will be
again from P to P it's the second
derivative operator it's still
linear okay it's still linear and of
course the third and so on they're all
linear fine
um
third set
well Vector
space of homo not homeo but
homomorphisms so the fun fun fact is the
following but uh it's a very useful fun
fact um if
V and
W and I now suppress the notation at
this this is the Plus on V and this is
the Plus on W because you yourself found
out you can always inspect the
expressions and you know okay so I
didn't need to uh write this down let
these be Vector spaces and we only do
real Vector spaces here this can be
slightly generalized to any underlying
number
field um let these be Vector spaces then
we can Define the set of all linear maps
from one to the other well we know what
a linear map is so I can collect all
linear Maps between these two specific
Vector spaces into a big bag and this
big bag is of course a set and
uh the set has a name and it need to say
it's with respect to which Vector space
is in which order and the set has a name
it's called H
VW it's just a funny name for a very
simple set the collection of all linear
maps and what is this this is a
set is this a vector space no not yet
but we can make this into a vector space
make this into a vector
space how do you do this well you
construct an addition on home
VW so you take two elements of the set
and you need to make a
prescription of how you get the sum of
these and you do this by taking a f and
the S linear maps from V to W and you
say their sum is five plus so now let me
um let me prescribe this by a plus with
a Circ it's just because it's yet a
different plus we have one plus another
plus and now we introduced the third one
now it's worth again introducing another
symbol but later on we'll drop the
circle you say this the sum of these two
but I need to say how the sum is defined
where five plus s well because they're
both linear Maps I can feed them a V and
I need to feed them a v uh and I Define
this as Fe of uh V plus s of V but uh
they take values in W so this is the
Plus on W here so I Define the Plus on
home VH by uh using the Plus on W and
similarly I don't write this down you
define the S
multiplication so the result is
if you start with two Vector spaces you
can immediately construct a third one
namely the set of all linear maps with
the such defined addition and S
multiplication and it's again an
assertion is a vector space of course
you need to check the axioms but that's
very
simple well this could be a curiosity
you could say okay you can look at the
linear Maps the vector spaces then they
themselves have a vector space structure
but of course this is kind of a tower of
structures you can continue like this
because this is now a vector space you
could look at maps from this Vector
space into another home uux or something
like this and then you have the H
squared and you have a tower of
structures this way and the vector space
structure inherits itself again and
again and
again we'll come back to this okay um
aha I lost a sheet of paper ah here
perfect okay so
example hang on is a vector yes that
this is a vector space so
example of course home
PP if you go from P to P that's again
our polinomial example Vector space of
polinomial Home PP is a vector space
okay what does that
mean well it means I can take an element
of Home PP for instance our Delta was an
element of Home PP y or it was a linear
map right was a linear map now we found
that the composition of linear Maps is a
linear
map so P Delta Delta the second
derivative operator was an element in
home PP and of course you can continue
like this you can go to the nth or MTH
derivative will be an element of Home
PP but because home PP carries a vector
space structure you can now look at for
instance Delta you take the Plus in in
home
PP you take the Plus in home PP and you
add to it the Delta Delta so you can
build a derivative operator of this form
and you can also have a five times in
front of here this is the times in home
PP so you have five times the first
derivative plus the second derivative
and you don't need to think you know
because this is a vector space the
result will lie in here again so if you
ever in doubt whether mixed order
derivative operators are still linear
well they
are okay you could check immediately but
the point is you see this is something
you do all the time you do all the time
so this home PP in this case is a very
natural object extremely natural to do
something like this right
okay so now comes a much
feared topic dual Vector
space and it's totally unclear why this
is such a a feared topic because we
already did it it's just a heavily used
special case of the stuff before it's a
heavily used special
case namely if you have a vector
space
V then you define a
set V Star first a
set as all the linear maps from V into
the real
numbers now you say oh into the real
numbers but but are they a vector space
yes the real numbers with their addition
and multiplication from elementary
school well the real numbers maybe not
good Elementary School um the real
numbers with plus and multiplication are
an R Vector space you can quickly check
they satisfy the aums so you can
justifiedly talk about the linear
structure okay but this is of course
home you tell me
home VR so it's just a very special case
of this home VW of this set but it's
heavily used and I can tell you already
why because if you know the V and the V
Star you can construct all the rest
that's the point it's an elementary
building block hence it's such a special
case but all the complicated cases you
can make out of the V and this building
block it's always clever to break
something down to its most Elementary
building blocks that's the only idea and
um now say oh this abst a very abstract
set you you take something it's a set of
maps well it's not so bad right you
understand the set of pols that's even
more complicated it's just the set of
linear
Maps now um well this is as a set and
but you have V Star with the plus and
the S
multiplication that is defined on here
right so that means I Define it just
like over here is a vector
space so it's a very special case how
from one vector space you make another
one it's this om VR case it's and this
guy here is called the
Dual Vector
space well to V it's the Dual of V it's
the Dual Vector space to
V
ahuh now again there comes some
terminology and it's as bad terminology
as it is for the vector but it's
commonly used terminology an element
Omega or fi element fi of the Dual space
is
called again
informally a CO
Vector a coor
but I mean V Star is a vector space in
its own
right so you could also call it a vector
because an element of a vector space is
a vector so you can say a co- Vector is
a vector now it becomes a little funny
the point is with co- Vector I mean I
think of a vector space V and I think of
its dual and it's my tcid agreement that
the elements of v i quickly refer to as
vectors and the elements of the
corresponding V Star I refer to as Co
vectors but actually Co the Co in front
only makes sense in relation to to the
vector space and so on so again you
cannot look at something and say oh this
is a co- Vector not a vector and um
anyway we we we'll come to this but we
we'll stick with terminology like this
so start thinking for some reason
naturally you're given a vector space
and the naturally will be the tangent
spaces to our manifold will be Vector
spaces and the elements of those you may
call vectors and the uh elements of the
Dual space to those you may call
Co vectors again terminology maybe
confusing terminology but commonly used
terminology you certainly want to get an
example you say this is so abstract
certainly you can't give an example with
these polinomial well of course I can
example consider a map I just call it I
uh that goes from P linearly into the
real numbers ah that must be an element
of P star so that is in other words I is
an element of P star so if I can Define
such a guy in a linear manner I have an
example uh and I define indeed this
specific I up here um
I of I need to say how a polom is mapped
here to a real number I take for
instance our polinomial are defined from
minus one to to One open interval I take
just for fun the integral from 0 to 1
doesn't matter whether the end point is
in there or not 0 to 1 DX P of
X you hand me a
polinomial and I integrate it from 0 to
one and doubtless I'll get a number a
real number is this in a Real Fashion is
this a linear map because it needs to be
a linear map in order to lie in here
well of course it is because if you take
two pols of course you can split the
integral because the sum of the two pols
we said that's the sum of the images of
the
pols and then you can split the integral
da da da and you get I of Q Plus I of p
and similarly you get I of Lambda p is
Lambda I of P again these are simple
rules of integration that you know and
simple rules of integration mean that
the operation of definite integration is
a co- Vector so
um that
is this map I as a map before it acts is
what you may write is 0 to 1 DX so the
integration operator that eats something
that's to the right of it is a co-
Vector okay so it's something you use
all the time in quantum mechanics you
come from the left with the derivative
operators or something like this can
come with an integral operator this is a
nothing it's a simple thing it's a co-
Vector is an element in P star p is the
space of these pols so again you use
this all the time and in fact we'll also
see later on that the gradient again you
have been indoctrinated that the
gradient of a
function on RN is a vector no no well
not if the vectors are the directions a
great is a co- Vector it must be a co-
vector and everything else gets you into
trouble and you can see it if you know
the multi-dimensional chain rule so if
you hold that the gradient is a vector
and you hold that the chain rule applies
you can prove anything because it's
inconsistent okay we we'll come to this
I just want to emphasize you met lots
and lots of lots of objects in your
physics physicist's lives that are co-
vectors but usually they have been
called vectors in order not to bother
you with these details but in in fact
the impression that covectors are
something extremely unnatural and
something very esoteric is simply
because people have lied to you okay
that's the only thing okay they're all
around and you know them you know many
examples of them without knowing
please okay again we will come back to
several of these several of these
points
okay so I said if you have a vector
space and you consider it's dual which
is a very special case of considering
linear maps from this Vector space into
another then you have the elementary
building
blocks to build this entire structure I
told you before where you Heap maps on
maps from maps to maps on each other and
always equip them with Vector space
structure and the elements of these
higher and higher and higher structures
they're just generically called tensors
so we're now going to introduce tensors
and tensors are such a natural object in
linear algebra you just need to write
them
down and um on finite dimensional Vector
spaces all of this is valid for any
Dimension first of all I didn't Define
Dimension yet but any Vector space
satisfies all of this so all I wrote
down is true for any Vector space no
what it's what we later call its
Dimension however at the end we will
introduce Dimension and basis and all of
that because is sometimes useful but it
introduces a great degree of
arbitrariness namely the choice of a
basis
um but um if you on finite dimensional
Vector spaces after all there is a very
simple way to think of tensors as
multilinear maps and that is what we're
going to introduce because the tangent
spaces to our man folds will be finite
dimensional if the DI manifold has
manifold Dimension as we defined it D
then the tangent spaces will have Vector
space Dimension D it's a different
notion of Dimension One is dimension of
a topological manifold which we defined
the other thing is the dimension of a
vector space of a tangent Vector space
and that will be the vector space
Dimension as we Define it but the two
numbers agree okay so therefore mostly
especially on when we apply the theory
to general relativity we'll only deal
with four dimensional Vector
spaces finite dimension of course four
is finite so we can think of tensors as
multi-linear maps and that's how I'm
going to introduce them
now so fifth is
tensors
okay so I just give you straight the
definition and then you'll see what I
mean by V and V Star Building being the
building blocks definition let V plus
times be a vector
space an r s
tensor over this Vector space V and R is
tensor over V and let's give it a name T
and R is tensor over
V is a
multi linear
map
T and now it comes that eats are many
copies of the Dual Vector
space and then it eats s
copies so obviously R and S are in
um R and S
are uh non- negative
integers and then it takes s copies of v
and it Maps these guys and remember if
you ask what are the copies of these
well these are tuples where the first
the elements of this set here so this is
a set right the elements of this set are
tuples where the first R in entries are
co- vectors and the last s entries are
vectors okay very simple thing uh into R
and again multil linearly well one is uh
tempted to write as many twiddles here
uh to write here R plus s
twiddles right because multilinearity
means and of course we won't do this we
will just write one t um because mult so
first of all the definition is finished
it's a multi-linear map uh that is so I
explain what multilinear means it's very
simple um Let me Give an example it's
best shown in an example and then you
know what multilinearity is uh let's say
t is a one one
tensor what does that mean it means T
can eat a co- vector and a
vector right so the FI I take from V
Star and the vector I take from V and um
multilinearity means that if
you take
two co- vectors F and S comma V that you
can pull it apart F comma V plus T comma
V so you only need one plus here and the
rest Remains the Same uh similarly um if
you have in this first entry Lambda fi
comma V you have Lambda goes all in
front F and V but of course what is true
for the first entry this would be a
linear map in the first entry a
multilinear map is quite independently
of being linear in the first entry it's
also linear in the second entry so F of
V + W is T of f comma v+ T of 5 comma W
and T of f comma
Lambda uh V is Lambda T of 5 comma
V so independent in both entries it's
linear um I continue the example with a
sub
example uh what is then T of uh F + S V
+ W well I need to use linearity twice
it's t of f v plus T of F W plus T of P
V plus T of w full
stop
yes go
forer
yes
okay yes yes yes
okay yes yes okay so the question is
let's do have Excursion it's a very good
question of
course we actually reserved it for the
problem sheet but because it's being
asked and the Excursion is that uh uh
the somebody in the audience
says um he Associates with the one one
tensor something you feed in a vector
and you get out a vector so I claim it's
precisely the same data so uh I do the
following construction then I answer the
question so
given a map T from V Star Cross V into
the the real numbers that's
multilinear I Define the following I
Define a map let's call it fi from the
data of this T so I say it's the FI
constructed from the T and this fi is a
map that takes a vector and spits out a
vector in linear fashion how does it do
that well I take a little vector v and I
spit out a vector in this fashion and ah
okay I get myself into trouble here um
aha okay I need to say it anyway so I'll
do it so this is T of what can the T do
the T can eat a vector in this slot and
a co- Vector in this slot so I put a
vector here but here I can't put
anything but so this is an object that
can eat a co- vector and spit out a real
number is that clear so that means what
is written here this guy eats a co-
vector and spits out a real number in
linear fashion because once the V is
fixed this is only linear in this slot
so this T here so this um result this
here doesn't land in v it lands in V
Star Star you see this so the result of
plugging in a V is an object that's a
linear map from here to here but a
linear map from a vector space into the
real number
is an element of the vector space taken
to the
star and now there is a fact that I'm
not going to prove right here but which
is true that if the dimension of the
vector space is less than
infinity if this is less than infinity
this is V the star star reproduces the V
but only for finite Dimension so after
all you constructed a map from V to V
and this is the way you like to think
about a one one tensor this is the way I
like to think about a one one tensor
because otherwise you would have to put
s you have put r v Stars here SVS here
and PV Stars here and qvs here and then
the tensor would be classified by being
an RSQ
tensor okay but I can save the trouble
because roughly speaking whenever I have
something here and can put it over here
by adding a star to it or if some V is
here I can put it over here also by
adding a star to it it always contains
the same data well I haven't proven that
yet because from this I constructed this
but the other way around I can say given
a map five from V to V again the way a
linear map again the way to you like to
think about a one one tensor I can
construct a map T but now the other way
around from the data of five which I
claim must be V Star Cross V into the
real numbers linearly by taking a co-
vector and taking a vector and making a
number out of it by taking this F you
provided we miss me we you provided me
with you map it by the FI and then you
apply this co- Vector here to make a
real number of it and then you have as a
fact from this you can show that if you
have
given given the T it's true that this T
can be recovered as the T that you get
from the FI that you constructed from
the T and given the FI like you like to
think about it you can reconstruct this
fi from the FI constructed from the
tensor constructed from the FI with
other words the way I like to think
about it and the way you like to think
about a one one tensor for finite
dimensional Vector space basis has the
same data it's the same thing but this
is a canonical notation for
it this was quick but maybe if you look
at the video you'll see it yes now you
sorry complain to the audience
please okay so the point is that since R
is a vector space we can say we get a V
and so the r is a vector space so there
following HS is that the point
of this year yeah no the point of this
year is that that a map from V to V
contains the same data as a map from V
Star Cross V to
R
okay that's that's the point of this
construction
okay good so we call these RS tensors
and your uh favorite tensors are in
there I give you an example and then I
still need to show you something namely
for instance that vectors are tensors
because that's also not obvious as
little as this is obvious what C asked
as little is it obvious that vectors are
tensors that co- vectors are tensors is
obvious but we'll do this first I'll
give you an example of a
tensor and again you think oh tensors we
never use them of course you use them
all the time the example is the
following you take a map
G taking two pols and mapping them
multil linearly into the real numbers
and um the specific map for instance
it's just an example for a one one
tensor a 02 tensor sorry is you take two
polinomial
PQ defined on where they are defined and
you say for instance the integral from
minus1 to 1 DX P of x q of
X you saw this so there was a question
about quantum mechanics well there we
want more fun functions than pols um but
nevertheless this is of course the inner
product on function space where the
functions are defined here so this
appears in quantum mechanics the inner
product okay well there it's complex
valued and so you take a little star
here and so on but that can all be be
done but this is our specific example
now this this exactly that it takes two
polinomial it Maps them to a real number
and of course it does so multi linearly
because if I take P plus P twiddle then
I can again pull the integral apart it
satisfies for instance also this Rule
and the question is it takes a p and a p
it doesn't take any P Stars uh so that
means this is a 0 to tensor over
p and inner product is a 02 tensor
there's nothing simpler than that okay
and a linear map from P to P like could
ask before is a one one tensor that's
it's all beautiful and of course it must
appear somewhere here because there's
linearity in the game and I promise you
that on finite dimensional Vector space
at least all these structures that Heap
on on each other and always inherit
their Vector space structure they will
all be constructable and that's the
point they're all constructable from
these Elementary building blocks V and V
Star and that's why they're so so
important okay good
uh one more piece of information I
really stop it
h if T lies in h v v h VW we looked at
this
before I don't want to say this okay
sorry it's um it can be done but it
leads too far okay let's leave this okay
fine question so
far good
now
sixth vector
and Co
vectors as
tensors uh well let's write this down as
a theorem but this is really a this is
Trivial theorem a co- Vector so an
element
fi in V Star what does it mean f lies in
V Star well by definition of V Star
V Star it means f is a linear map from V
to R
agreed but that by definition of tensors
is a 0o one
tensor because it takes zero times the V
St so a co- Vector you can call this a
co- Vector if you like a co- Vector is
by the definitions a 01
tensor I mean this is is theorem and
proof in one right theorem including
proof
okay now not quite so obvious but
because of course
question it's now easy for me to
argue a vector V in V what does that
mean well a vector V in V I claim no I
don't claim I already I already claimed
I only claim once without proof uh V is
V Star
star Remember for dim
V less than infinity and that's a little
silly because I haven't defined dim V
but I will do that in a second okay dim
V is V Star Star you can construct the
point is probably I see the
mathematician move you probably want the
isomorphism I'm just saying that purpose
of this the sufficient that is a
subset the subset of star that's true in
or but also in order to do the opposite
direction
then okay so we agree it's true what I
write but I could write something weaker
okay okay good so I have this but if
this is true I just by definition of the
star I then know that V is a linear map
from V Star to R in the sense of it has
the same information I can construct
this linear map from a given V and I can
reconstruct the V from the given map
that's the name of the game uh but this
now is in a form congenial to our
definition of tensors this means that V
is a one Zer
tensor thank good so vectors are one
zero
tensors can be considered one Zer
tensors Co vectors are 01 tensors linear
maps are 1 one
tensors and so on okay uh an inner
product for instance on a vector space
if you give one it's additional it's
data right an inner product is an
example for a 02
tensor an inverse of an inner product
it's usually called an inverse it should
call be should be called the Dual inner
product would be a two Z tensor it would
be an inner product on the Dual space
it's stand a two tensor and so on okay I
claim that everything that written here
in terms of tenses you have many many
examples seen in your physics classes
and probably never called them
tensors
okay a homework the in inertia tensor of
classical mechanics the tensor of
inertia what is r and what is s well it
has two indices oh shouldn't say this
okay we come to this later okay anyway
the question is anyway is it a 1 one
tensor a two tensor or a 02
tensor go to your mechan P book and look
at it okay good so uh this is that now
uh Blackboard
please so all of this has been said
without ever talking about a basis
without ever talking about the
components of a vector and in fact in
terms of this polinomial without even
thinking about the Vector being a
collection of numbers right there are no
collections of any numbers anywhere
they're just vectors and with the
polinomial of course hidden somewhere
this is there but that's not the point
the point is to not see it if you don't
see the numbers in the vectors you did
well okay you did well
now because you did well because that is
the structure of the whole thing okay
anything that can be constructed this
way is natural you can make your proofs
and so on now there is a notion of basis
of a vector space and bases of the Dual
Space special bases of the Dual space so
called dual spaces of the Dual space and
we'll do all of that and it has its
place name it has its place if you ask
me well for it has its place but the
point is in order to assum associate to
a vector a collection of
numbers well first of all it should be a
finite dimensional Vector space in order
to really make this working but in order
to do this you cannot just do this I
okay I could take give you the
polinomial X2 + x to the 3r it's an
element of the P Vector space and I
asked you what numbers does it
correspond to what's the collection of
numbers the point is there uncountably
many ways you can associate this one
vector to a set of numbers numbers you
can there uncountably many ways and the
choice of one of these ways is called a
choice of
bases but it's a choice that has nothing
to do with the object you wrote down for
instance in quantum mechanics you have
an inner product and the inner product
is what counts now of course you can
make an additional choice you can make a
choice one out of uncountably many you
make a pick I mean that's a a lot of
information right if you have
uncountably many choices and you make
one it's a lot of
information well you can do this and as
long as you keep in mind that you made a
massive Choice a massive choice and that
everything you now write down using this
choice will depend on this choice you
can then earn the fruit of having made
this choice but never ever should you
think think that what you write down
having made this Choice has any
objective well reality is a bad word but
has anything to do with the vector alone
it has to do with the vector and the
massive choice you made so you see it's
a very mixed blessing to choose a basis
nevertheless we'll do it because it's
quite practical in some places to do
very explicit calculations but actually
so uh in England they say a gentleman
and of course today a lady only chooses
a basis if he or she has to so unless
you're really forced because it gets
really better don't choose a basis in
the first place okay good now having
been sufficiently poic about choice of
bases uh I introduced them it's seven I
think yes
seven Aces definition
let V be a vector
space a
subset B in
V is
called a
basis and if you want to be very and
this is the basis I'm going to Define is
the basis from your linear algebra
lecture
however because you're physicist I have
to warn you in quantum mechanics you
often have bases with infinitely many
elements and you combine a vector by a
series by a infinite sum of basis
vectors but that basis I just mentioned
in quantum mechanics is not the basis of
linear algebra although most books
testly assume this or at least don't
mention the opposite so in order to see
the difference we call this a HL basis
and this is the basis of linear algebra
so this is the basis if you're a
mathematician you don't think of INF
anyway this if you're a mathematician
Hil basis a subset B andv is called a
basis if now I could go into this long
thing about generating system and linear
Independence but a good way to say it is
is a um is called a basis
if and now the order is uh important
if for all V in the vector
space there exists and now it comes a
finite it's important word a finite
subset
um f f like finite which lies in the
bases so there must for you first pick a
vector and then you see whether your
basis set which may be a set with
infinitely many
elements but you see whether for a given
Vector you find finitely many F in here
well if this is finite it can be written
as fub1 to FN whatever the N is that for
this Vector you find this n might vary
with this Vector you there exists a
finite subset in the spaces such that
there exist
unique unique numbers V1 V2
to VN they're all real numbers such that
V can be
written and I think this is also a
unique finite subset that the V can be
written as uh
V1
fub1 plus do plus VN FN
yes
um
yes yes okay um so you don't want
this I don't think so because um I know
I I roughly I think I know what you mean
but it could be that in another part of
this B There is yet another set of these
such that again you can write this
concrete v as this so the question was
cameraman indicates um the question was
is there an exclamation mark here or not
exclamation mark means exist unique a
unique Choice um there could be in this
B another stretch of vectors such that
the V can be alternatively expressed
using them so then I think uh that would
be go against what you usually split up
as the linear Independence of the
basis um so I I think it's uh it's it's
correct but I think that you're safe if
you say if youate that these are in R
without zero yes the point yes but okay
then then it becomes the philosophical
question if you have a serious where you
know that almost all members are zero
whether it's still a serious or
not if it a series becomes a sum if yeah
okay something like this okay let let's
keep it like this so the whole the whole
point here is that really a basis can be
have infinitely many elements but you
always must aim at being able to
represent given vector by only finitely
many from this basis because then you
have a sum otherwise you would have a
series here on the right hand side and
if you have a series you know a series
only converges if you have a notion of
convergence so in order to be able to
require anything but a Hil basis you
would need a topology on your vector
space as well only if you also have a
topology on top of the vect Vector space
structure then you can start thinking
about defining bases in a way that
you're more liberal here and that's
called then a Sher basis okay and that's
usually what you do in quantum mechanics
anyway this is this that was just
confusing me if I take a simple Oneal
harmonic oscillator and the energy
ionian functions there are infinitely
many so why is there this stressing it's
a finite number well the point is those
IG functions wouldn't constitute a HL
basis of your Hilbert space they would
constitute a Sher basis and for that you
need additional structure on your
Hilbert space which you do have because
your Hilbert space has an inner product
it's a complete space so you have you
have this norm and it's complete and so
on so the it converges and and therefore
you can do it but that is not the basis
of linear algebra it's it's a basis on a
topological Vector space not a BAS basis
on a bare Vector
space so again it's how much structure
exactly you you assume so this is the
basis of linear algebra okay that's this
so
definition
if there exists a
basis B with finitely many elements now
B itself has finitely many
elements say a d
many
then we
call D the dimension of the vector
space the number of elements in a base
now of course you might ask hang on
there is maybe not a unique basis I said
there isn't more than countable
countably many bases of course there are
uh what if I choose another basis well
you have to show well definition and I
just asserted this is well
defined for any other basis then uh any
other basis then has the same number of
elements and this is then a finite
dimensional Vector
space so now once we made this
definition we can say what a finite
dimensional Vector space is if you start
with the definition you always have a
finite basis then you never know whether
you you got them all right
okay and as I said uh we will
occasionally use an infinite dimensional
Vector space but we will never need to
choose a basis for those we will mainly
deal with finitely finite dimensional
Vector spaces and we will never need but
we will often do choose a basis for
those okay
good um next
point is
this choice so let me make a remark here
remark um and for Simplicity I from now
on we'll only assume we have a finite
dimensional Vector space but only for
Simplicity okay remark so let V
plus uh times be a v be a
finite dimensional Vector
space
then choosing or having chosen a basis
having chosen chosen a
basis let's say E1 to e n i called it f
before now I call it e E1 to n of this
Vector
space we may
uniquely
associate with a vector a tuple of
numbers namely with the vector you may
associate a tuple of numbers V1 to v
n called the vector components where the
V1 yeah well
called the
components of V with respect ECT to The
Chosen
basis so a vector doesn't have
components all by itself but only once
you chose a basis where and I have to
tell you how I get these numbers where
these V's are the unique numbers are the
unique numbers such that I write V1 E1
plus plus VN N I recover the
vector okay yeah but this requires
The Chosen
basis so if you choose a basis you have
to always keep it in mind and everything
you say depends on
that so you may introduce a choice of
basis but you pay a big cost everything
will depend on an arbitrary Choice yes
well I guess we are all exhausted but
you probably won't like if I ask this
question at the beginning of the next
lecture we introduced charts last time
and there you also stressed uh that
depends on the publisher what our
coordinator or however we call are so
now why is it bad here and wasn't so bad
there it's bad there
too and hence I only would buy a so the
question is why uh if you introduce
charts uh you have an arbitrariness here
you introduce basis you have arbit is
it's as bad and hence I would only buy
an atlas from a publisher who sells me a
maximal atlas that has all the charts in
it and then I will always make sure that
everything I want to Define is
independent of my fantasy I talked about
this last time it's the same here you
can introduce a basis and then Define
Concepts using the objects defined in
this bases but then you have to make
sure that under a change of bases the
objects are not changed for instance the
determinant of a linear map you can
Define this in this funny way if you use
choose a bases and Associate a matrix to
it you can do this but then you have to
check that under change of bases it's
invariant well my advice would be never
introduce a basis in the first place and
Define the determinant basis free the
same is true for the trace of a map for
instance and so on so that's exactly
it's exactly the philosophy so um I need
to do uh two more things and that's uh
fifth it's a
basis the Dual
space now having chosen a basis choose
basis say E1 to n for V of course you
can
choose you can choose a
basis Epsilon one to Epsilon n i
indicate this by upstairs Ines for V
Star entirely independently of your
choice of bases on V because V Star is a
different Vector space and if you have
you can choose on V to different bases
you can also choose on V1 basis and on V
Star a basis that has nothing to do
whatsoever with the Bas is chosen on V
so you make double you introduce double
as much arbitrariness right um well that
becomes a little silly especially
because you may so it's more economical
however more
economical to
require that once a basis E1 en n on V
has been
chosen
that the basis on V Star satisfies that
the eighth basis element on V Star what
is that that's an element that's an
object that sends a vector to real
number
right that it eats the be if it eats the
be basis element on V that what you get
out is what we abev as Delta up a down B
which is one if a equals B and is zero
if a not equal to
B you can require this and this
uniquely
determines
choice of the
epsilons the co- vectors from the
choice backboard please from the choice
of um Vector bases E1 to
n okay and this special choice if the
basis of the Dual space
definition if a
basis Epsilon 1 to Epsilon n of V Star
satisfies
this it is called because it's Unique I
can call it
the Dual
basis and of course it's the basis of
the Dual space
I call it the Dual basis of the Dual
space and the whole purpose is we
already made a choice keep the choices
down by linking the two together it's a
matter of economy and an additional
benefit it is it makes the formulas
simpler in many
places
okay
example
you remember our space
p and let's say the n in there is fixed
to three now I said it was the
polinomial of degree at most P what is
the basis for p
E1 well there I would like to start
calling with e0 but you know that
doesn't make a
difference um e0 1 2 3 so it's a four
dimensional space apparently uh this is
a
basis if now I need to say how they're
defined well a vector is a polom so that
means this basis Vector is a polom and I
say it's the polom that's just defined
as one E1 of X X2 E2 of x x to the X to
the cube now it's suffices hang on one
no here x x² and E3 of x = x cubed I
claim this is a basis if the objects are
defined like
this because every polom up to degree
three you can write down as a linear
combination of these guys well of
course okay now the question is what on
Earth is the Dual basis e0 E1 E2
E3 and I already write down the Dual
basis of the Dual space that satisfies
this and this is defined by taking the E
Epsilon I could have also written here e
down a is X to the a okay here I write
so let's do this uh e down a of X is
defined as x to the a it's a choice of
bases I could choose a totally different
one what's the Dual
vectors the Dual vectors
are 1 over a factorial 0 factorial is
one and then you take the it's only one
dimension but I use this as the Der
derivative operator you take the eth
derivative of whatever this acts on
because this is in a dual space it acts
on pols so it can act on that a times
and after it acted you evaluate at x
equal
Z that sends a polom to a number take a
polom you calculate
1/ a factorial times the eth derivative
of the polinomial is a polinomial and
then you evaluate at
zero claim this is the Dual basis to
this so here the elements of the Dual
base are not pols they're derivative
operators with an evaluation
proof Epsilon a on EB equals well uh you
apply this to here you get
um if you have the eighth derivative you
get a factorial in front you evaluate at
zero and then you check that all the
lower orders have been killed only the
eighth order and the be order is Pres
oberved and all the higher orders are
being set to zero indeed this is Delta a
check
it bear with me for four more minutes
this is the Dual base of the Dual Vector
space and now comes something everybody
has been waiting for who knew tensors
before namely components of
tensors
let
definition let T be an RS
tensor
over a finite
dimensional Vector space
V
then
Define the r + S to the dimension V
many real
numbers I call them T like the Kern
letter of the the tensor is called but
now I write T i1 to i r J1 to
JS and all the
I i1 to I and all the J1 and J to JS
they can all run from one to dimension
of
v it could be T 1 1 2 3 seven if seven
is still less or equal to the dimension
so you can have all combinations that's
why you have so many numbers and all of
these guys it's just a name for fixed
for fixed numbers 1 1 74 da da this is
an element of the real numbers okay how
is it defined well you're given a tensor
uh real numbers defined as you take the
tensor and now comes the point you
cannot Define numbers from a tensor
unless you chose a basis so you need to
say let be a
tensor and E1 to n basis of
v and then you can plug in for the
last s elements you can plug in ei1 the
i1 basis tensor here the IC and so on to
the I A J J1 J2 to the j s now whatever
values this takes you plug this in and
what do you plug in here well you need
in order to get a number from from these
indices you plug in the DU Epsilon i1
down to Epsilon iir then you fill the r
slots and it's a silent agreement that
the Epsilon one to Epsilon n is the Dual
basis of the Dual space the tested
agreement is that you did this you can
do it differently but you get yourself
more work on your hands so you take a
tensor and you plug in your massive
choice of bases all possible
combinations and you get a massive array
of
numbers why is this a good idea well
first of all you can Define it the
question is is it useful and this is
useful so these are called the
components these are called the
components of the
tensor with respect to the chosen
bases
and why is this
useful
knowing the
components and the bases with respect to
which the components have been defined
you have to keep the bases in mind one
can
reconstruct
construct the entire tensor
and I just do this in an example it's
very clear say so
example say t is a one one
tensor then its components are t i j are
the application of here the J basis
vector and here the I dual basis
vector and when I say I can reconstruct
the entire tensor what I the the tensor
is a map and I certainly understand the
map if I can calculate any image if I
can take any element in the domain and I
can calculate what it is I understand
the map so let's do this how do I
reconstruct
reconstruct I can expand the FI in the
co basis so there it has a
sum I = 1 to a dimension of v five
Epsilon uh I and the components are f i
these are the components of the co-
Vector I can expand I = 1 to dim V the
vector that's the components of the
vector so these guys I in the real
numbers but these are Co vectors and
these are vectors now because T is
multilinear I can pull out the
sums here and here so you get a double
sum you can do this in steps if you wish
I should write this with with a J in
order not to get into trouble IAL 1 to
dim V Jal 1 to dim V I can also pull out
real numbers so I can pull out the f i
in front and the VJ and All That Remains
is the T Epsilon i e j these I cannot
pull out because they're not numbers but
they're vectors but this is exact
definition of the IJ component of the
tensor so you can calculate if you
decompose the um domain elements in
terms of their bases you can then write
understand the mapping of this tensor by
doing this here and you just make this
big sum and one last remark the called
the Einstein summation convention if you
have tensors of higher rank there will
be many sums and many indices but it
will always be and this came from my
choice that I didn't explain because
it's the convention that I label
different basis vectors by an index down
and I label different Co vectors B in
the bases by indices up and if I do this
and I further agree that I then label
the components here with indices down
and those components with indices up
then I have a nice convention that
multiply occurring in PES like this I
down and this I up always appear up down
and this J up and this J down again
appear in an up down combination and
they will only always here appear by
being summed
over so what one does one defines the
following
expression um f i v j t i up I down J it
has multiple indices and you say what
are I and J and the answer is if you
have an index down and an index up there
is an
invisible sum sign in front of it
summing over the index and if you have
yet another index up
down twice up down there is yet another
invisible sum
sign and it would be a very bad idea
making some signs invisible because if
they're invisible they can be pulled out
without being seen it's like a ghost so
if you have a linear map and you have a
sum over
vectors and the sum sign is invisible I
wouldn't know is it here or is it here
because in both cases it's invisible but
it doesn't matter whether it's here or
here because if the map is linear you
can pull it in or out so making some
science invisible is only working
because you have you always look at
multilinear
Maps so the ghost is not seen but it's
not necessary to see whether the ghost
is in or out and this is called the
Einstein summation convention and it
saves you a lot of writing effort and it
makes the formula appear much
clearer repeated indices one up one down
are being summed
over next lecture in half an hour and uh
tutorials this afternoon thank you very
much